I want to pull up this clip from Michael
Knowles now I don't normally play clips
from other people's show but a lot of
people are shouting out that Lauren
bobert appeared on Michael Knowles's
show and so I don't want to piggyback
their content but guys you know this is
big so shout out to Michael Knowles and
I want to play this uh statement from
from Lauren Boberg might be able to
figure out people are saying that once
they heard Lauren bobert lay this out
they really went hard against McCarthy
figure out if they had an ounce of
self-awareness but they don't so instead
they're blaming Lauren bobert we have
Lauren on the call Lauren thank you so
much I know you're very very busy right
now but thank you for making time to
come on the show
absolutely thanks so much for having me
on Michael so Lauren where does it all
stand we've given a recap of of the the
speaker fight through last night on the
show Kevin McCarthy lost three rounds of
voting two days ago he loses three runs
of voting yesterday you and those
terrible evil House Freedom caucus
Republicans you're you're not budging
here so what happens
well let's begin at where it started
this started in the summer we wanted to
handle this privately
um and and have a solution before
January 3rd these negotiations began in
the summer and they were dismissed
because Kevin McCarthy thought he was
going to have this massive Red Wave and
our votes did not matter when he saw
that the 300 million dollars that he
raised did not produce the red wave that
he promised he realized quickly he's
going to need our votes and so some
concessions
um were were put into play it was very
difficult to get them into play it was
difficult to get them approved with our
rules process the Way Washington D.C
operates and functions we want to
fundamentally change this town it is
broken it is less popular with the
American people than cockroaches so we
have to get something right here and we
cannot go along with the status quo well
on January 2nd um two of my fellow
colleagues and myself Matt Gates Scott
Perry we walked into
leader McCarthy's office after whipping
votes all day long and handed him 218
votes we said here it is let's seal the
deal here's some common sense issues
that you can put forward some promises
that you can make single member motion
to vacate so there is accountability on
the third in line to the presidency of
the United States you cannot demand more
responsibility and follow Nancy Pelosi's
precedence of less accountability so
this is our check and balance on the
speaker and that was a priority for me
personally certainly and for many others
but then things like bring the Texas
border plan to the floor for a vote
bring a term limits Bill to the floor
for a vote any member who wants to
reduce spending in an amendment will
make that amendment in order so we can
bring it to the floor and have a vote
earmarks bring them to the floor oh no
we got an ad uh Capital yeah Brave bro
we do use Brave we do actually you got
an ad on that yeah we can skip it sorry
Michael here we go we're back a vote
this is spending money that we do not
have so let's at least have a vote on it
instead of packing it into a bill where
we'd have no option to either swallow
the whole thing or say no way uh
um these are things that we presented to
him he uh solicited a list from us of
committee assignments all members
provide committee assignment requests we
know where our talents and skills are
are best utilized I wanna I wanna point
out real quick though I think what's big
here is she mentioned McCarthy thought
he was going to get a red wave which
meant he didn't need to actually go to
the freedom caucus for anything because
he wouldn't need their votes he thought
they were probably going to have what
like 240 seats
and then when they realized it wasn't
manifesting it's like uh oh so this guy
it sounds like really McCarthy did it to
himself and we provided that list
um Kevin McCarthy made a great argument
saying listen the people in this group
only want two committees I need you
spread out I want you to have more
influence and we agreed with that and we
said you know this is a time constraint
on many of the members that's a lot of
responsibility a lot of pressure but
we're willing to take that sacrifice and
have these committee assignments that
bear more pressure and so we provided
that to him and then January 2nd when
all of that was laid on the table
Kevin McCarthy laughed us out of the
room said that it was a selfish wish
wish list and would not take the deal
well now here we stand Michael I no
longer have those 218 votes to provide
to Kevin McCarthy so it doesn't matter
if I go to the floor today and vote for
Kevin McCarthy because there are now
more than ever votes that he does not
have to get to that speakership this is
very important to know he walked out of
that meeting and lied about what we
requested trust is absolutely broken if
there were if there was any to begin
with and this is a huge problem we want
unity in the Republican party and I
believe now is the time to start
seriously considering consensus
candidates who will unify the Republican
party so we can get to work for the
American people so Byron Donald's is
that guy yep why do you think I just
like his personality he's six two two
sixty five man that did you see that
interview where they're like what do you
think about them threatening something
something in you he's like do you know
six two 260. I'm not afraid of that he's
like I'm not scared yeah they're
retaliated because they were using those
words like threaten and are you gonna
fight on the floor of Congress are you
gonna fight for you and he's like yo and
he just turned around on an actual fight
like they're not actually gonna fight
they're not actually threatening each
other just because someone might lose
their job you know because you could
argue getting your your income taken
away could be a form of life-threatening
uh that was that was a Chad Alpha
statement when he just smiled and said
I'm six two 265 I'm not worried Byron
come on in man I want to get Lauren in
here too these guys are close by I think
it might be even a weekend if you guys
are up for a weekend we could go down
there or something but I want to kind of
amplify the messages we about to say
something yeah just that I'm glad the
Patriots uh in the Republican Party are
holding out people right very good
people like say his name again people
like Ali Alexander have been enduring
lawfare from the January 6 committee for
like two years now they made him spend
his life savings they made him defend
himself for eight hours and if he said
one word wrong they would have tried to
throw him in prison like they did to
Roger Stone so the fact that this
January 6 committee exists it's been
pushing lies it's been used as lawfare
to try and decapitate the strongest
political leaders on the right now that
we have the house we but now that the
Republicans have the house they should
use the January 6 committee and actually
do something for the Patriots for their
constituents and go and investigate what
have the Democrats been doing with this
committee what happened on January 5th
was this whole thing some sort of psyop
that was ginned up by the intelligence
agencies because it looked like they got
a lot going on there revolver news has
had a lot of reporting about that Ray
apps with the transcripts that got
released we absolutely need to see them
go after that that's right maybe I want
it's the weirdest thing when uh the
transcript comes out and there's a quote
from Ray app saying that he orchestrated
he texted someone saying that and then
kittensinger tweeted out that it was
completely untrue it is shocking to me
that there can be a transcript you can
read and these people are just smiling
like never happened but there are people
stupid enough to believe him he's on
video cheering this whole thing on
orchestrating it and then another
question is who opened those doors those
magnetic doors that couldn't be opened
by humans but were open from the inside
those are important questions that we
deserve to know what actually happened
here who opened those doors why was
security called off what in the world
was going on here with Ray apps there's
a lot of questions I think those
questions deserve to be answered and the
January 6th commission was is not
answering them the video of them opening
the doors you're talking about is really
the magnetic doors yeah it's from inside
the building ends there's people outside
yelling and then someone walks up to the
magnetic door sealed doors they're
barred shut they look back and like
point up at someone and then the doors
are magnetically unlocked and opened and
all these people start pouring in who
opened the door who verified the door
being able to push the I want to know
too it's crazy video
because someone look for all we know
someone broke into the security booth
and hit the button maybe okay let's
let's get that video released so we can
figure out what's going on I thought
that would have been a talking point by
the corporate media and the Democrats
look at these they had Insider knowledge
they knew what their door they did they
ran dry drills they they knew where the
button was we haven't had any of that
but they would have sensationalized it
to the highest degree that they could
sorry I was just thinking about If there
really was like real violent uh damage
done that day like if people went in
with weapons and started shooting the
the cops in the building would have
killed a bunch of people and then put a
ton of people in prison and it would
have been a really big deal but it was
just like a guy in a viking suit
laughing as people around them were like
yeah dude I mean I'm not saying for
there was violence going on today wasn't
wasn't that guy like telling a cop who
was like sorry yeah we'll get out of
here man we're actually really
disrespectful Jason rink is directing a
film about him called Q sent me and he's
got hours of interviews with uh the Q
Shaman and basically the guy is a
well-meaning dude that walked in you
know he was allowed into the building
and they're treating him like he's Osama
Bin Laden it's the craziest thing in the
world wasn't he on mushrooms what was or
is that or am I wouldn't be surprised
are you confusing with me is that what
you're saying maybe yeah they just
realized mushrooms in Oregon first time
first state it's completely
recreationally legal now I just saw
Dennis McKenna tweeted it out anyway
let's get back to I don't know if he was
on mushrooms or not I wouldn't be
surprised that's the kind of thing
people have done on when you're dosing
hard I've seen that trip yeah a lot of
people have pointed out that hearing
Lauren Baldwin on Michael Knowles's show
made them really just anti-mccarthy and
I I agree you know we we don't listen to
everything about it so you should
definitely check out Michael knows
interview with her I don't want to you
know just ride the whole the whole
segment but uh I I agree I had heard
rumors about it but the the main point
is that
they had an opportunity in the summer to
do a deal McCarthy thought he wouldn't
need it the Republicans performed
terribly for a variety of reasons now
he's desperate and he can't get it good
you reap what you sow man if we can't if
they can't I say we but it's them
unfortunately they're representing we
the people uh if we can't get to a
consensus about who is are we just going
to sit here for the next six seven eight
weeks and start every show is just like
the house is there again watch them go
home for dinner at eight right before we
need popcorn first of all right and uh
yeah hell yeah why not
yeah I called it life and death last
night people were like oh haha Ian
called this life and death but I mean
it's the it's the the leadership of the
most powerful military on Earth is now
finding itself in a gridlock pattern
which is I'm chilling I'm chilling I
mean American citizens are pretty much
in the same state they were last week I
think the bigger issue is that tomorrow
everyone's like I'm over it dude we get
it Kevin McCarthy can't win why do they
keep doing this you know I get it the
alternative is what a motion to adjourn
that's not gonna work I I think if I
would like can we get a motion to never
be allowed to a journal until this is
resolved that's what I'd vote for I beg
no one's leaving their job is basically
to sit around as it is is like the
easiest look right now there's some dude
loading bags into a truck loading boxes
into a Truck heavy lifting covered in
sweat his back is hurting and is getting
paid less than these people to sit
around and complain about each other
this is why I'm afraid or concerned
about leaving it up to the con to the
house to find their own speaker because
it they are going to break each other's
will and then just browbeat people down
to like okay fine I don't care anymore
take it take whoever you want that's not
the way you elect leadership we need the
people deciding who is going to be the
voice of that of that movement well I'll
say it's tough for us to decide who's
going to be be the voice of that
movement I'm I'm living in Arizona I
love Arizona I think it's the greatest
state in the country and right now I was
there it took three hours for me to vote
I watched a ton of people get out of
line they had all kinds of malfunctions
where the voting machines were not
taking you know the the you know 19
inches instead of 20 is what they said
yeah the bat was rejecting the the
machine was rejecting the ballot they
were rejecting the ballots and the
tabulators and they had a two-day trial
if you watch that trial Shane Cashman
timcast.com wrote an incredible article
about it yeah Shane's great Shane's a
great I want to meet Shane he's cool
yeah he wrote him cooler after you meet
him his article was really good and it
was not assertive he didn't come out and
say this definitively was this he said
here's the evidence presented here's
what I experienced the media wasn't even
talking about the evidence that the
Witnesses were presenting it's crazy so
the judge in that case I don't know how
the judge got to the conclusion after
those two days when every Republican
Witness
said factually here is what happened
like this is against the law this is
crazy there's no chain of custody and
then the Democrat witnesses there the
Democrat lawyers are flustered it's
crazy and then to dismiss that case well
I'll put it I'll put it very lightly
there are bad judges who make bad
rulings
if if however you want to interpret that
Carrie likes appealing so the
interesting thing is that moving forward
I don't know it too much about it but
I'm very optimistic my understanding is
that the argument made by Kerry Lake's
legal team
is based on precedent set by the same
court she's now petitioning so it would
be really really I think they planned
this like I I like you you can't imagine
that Kerry Lake's legal team after
seeing everything they've seen did not
have a plan in place it would be really
weird if the Arizona I think they're
going to the Arizona Supreme Court
rejected its own precedence and said no
actually we changed our mind on it would
it would just be like it's kind of
setting them up you know it'd be a
little bit like 2020 and repeat the fact
that not a single Supreme Court case was
held in 2020 was just insane I mean it's
it's not crazy precedent Bush V Gore we
saw it in 2000 that they will hear a
case okay what's going on with the
elections but we didn't even get to hear
a case in 2020 and for the Arizona
Supreme Court if they don't have the
courage to hear this case then I
question the legitimacy of our entire
country you can give a shout out to
Thomas and Alito who agreed to hear the
Texas VPN I think was Texas V
Pennsylvania and then you had uh you had
um Coney Barrett you had Kavanaugh who
said no he had Robert said no so I mean
look some of these are Trump's Trump's
appointees true and they and and the
issue is when that suit happened and
this is a lawsuit it's an argument that
never got to happen okay it's questions
about the legality of voting procedure
nothing to do with fraud they called it
a fraud lawsuit over and over again the
Press because they were lying this was
Texas saying we don't think the
procedure held in the in the in the law
by Pennsylvania is in line with the
Constitution uh dictates and and the
Supreme Court is supposed to handle
original jurisdiction that is disputes
between states Thomas and Alito both
agreed whether we want to or not we are
obligated to take up a court case
between states and then everyone else
just said we're not getting anywhere
near this and so now you have people who
are upset that these questions didn't
get resolved what ends up happening
Arizona and now you have people whose
confidence in the system is shattered I
have to wonder if that's what they
wanted
I have to say because you mentioned
Trump earlier these are Trump's justices
Trump listened to McConnell McConnell
picked the justices for him and Trump
has had track record of putting the
worst people around him picking the
worst people around him he endorsed
McCarthy for this uh speaker race that
we're all enjoying where McCarthy is
failing over and over and over again and
Trump you know for people I love him I
voted for him I tried everything I could
to help get him in office both times but
I think he's retired and we should want
him to be retired because he doesn't
know how to put competent people around
him thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time